- To infinity and beyond.
- No. [chuckles]
Live long and prosper.
- All right,
you're gonna teach me.
- You have all your
fingers together...
- I do.
- And then,
you just go like this.
- [groans] Stay together.
- Put them all together.
- Okay.
- And then, just...
- I do this.
I go there.
- No, that's--
that's the shocker. [laughs]
- Oh.
- Hi, I'm Ashley Nicole Black,
and today we're talking about
Nichelle Nichols.
So it's 1964,
and Nichelle Nichols
guest stars
on an episode of a show
called "The Lieutenant,"
that's run by
Gene Roddenberry.
And Gene Roddenberry was like,
you're amazing;
you're so beautiful.
Do you wanna be on this
new show called "Star Trek"?
Here's my plan.
It's gonna be super utopian,
and black ladies
can be bosses,
so this is exactly
a really big deal.
So Nichelle Nichols is like,
that sounds chill as hell,
so let's do that show.
So they start
filming "Star Trek,"
and Nichelle Nichols plays
Lieutenant Uhura,
who's the communications
officer, so she's like,
Captain, I have something
to communicate with you.
Boo-boo-boo-boo-boo.
And she has nails that are
way too long for space.
But also...
Nichelle Nichols doesn't
actually watch the show,
because back then,
TV came on at a certain time,
and she was at work
during that time.
So at the end of
the first season,
she's like,
"Star Trek" is cool, whatever.
I don't know
if anybody watches it.
But my dream
is to be on Broadway.
I wanna sing.
I wanna dance.
And she goes to
Gene Roddenberry,
and she's like,
hey, I'm gonna go to Broadway,
so I'm done Trekking.
I'm done.
So, he tells her,
like, please,
just, like, take the weekend
to think about it.
And she was like,
whatever, bitch, fine.
So that weekend,
Nichelle Nichols goes to
an NAACP fundraiser,
and one of the organizers
comes up to her,
and is like,
hey, there's a guy here,
and he's your biggest fan,
and he really wants
to meet you.
And she's like,
okay, cool, whatever.
Bring on the nerd.
And she sees her fan,
and he's like,
your show is the only show
that I allow
my three little children
to stay up and watch.
We love "Star Trek."
It's so good.
And she's like, excuse me,
are you Martin Luther King?
And he's like, yes,
I am Martin Luther King,
and I'm a Trekkie.
And she's like, [bleep] me.
- [chuckles]
- But it's real.
Martin Luther King
loved "Star Trek."
And he's like,
you are the only
black woman on television
who doesn't play a servant.
You're the only person
out there providing hope
to black people
that there's a future,
where maybe they won't be
seen as less than,
and they'll be seen as equals.
And she's like,
wow, that's great,
except for I'm leaving.
I quit "Star Trek" this week.
I'm so sorry.
And he's like,
no, you can't quit.
Do you realize that you are
the first black
"women" who's--
black woman.
He wasn't drunk
when he said it.
- No, it's okay.
- I was drunk.
But Martin Luther King
was like, if you leave,
this one image
that children have
of a black woman as an equal
will just disappear
from television.
And she's like,
well, [bleep], that's a lot.
That's, like, a lot.
That's a lot on my shoulders.
Can you chill?
And he's like,
No, I'm Martin Luther King.
I have no chill.
And she was like,
okay, I'll think about it.
Stay tuned
for more "Drunk History."
Do you know how the first
interracial kiss
on television happened?
- So Nichelle Nichols goes
into Gene Roddenberry's office,
and she's like, Gene,
I met Martin Luther King
this weekend,
and he really likes your shit.
And he's like, oh, my God...
[gasps] Someone understands
what I'm trying to do here.
She's like, oh, my God,
shut the [bleep] up.
That's not the point.
The point is, this show
is going to advance
racial equality.
I'll stay on your show.
So, you know,
they're filming "Star Wars."
It's great.
- Is that true?
- Oh, my God.
[laughter]
Also very good.
So they're doing "Star Trek."
It's great. People love it.
At some point,
Gene Roddenberry's like,
I know--we're gonna
push the envelope.
We're gonna have
the first interracial kiss.
And William Shatner
is like, hell yes.
And Nichelle Nichols
is like, whatever, fine.
But the network came down
and was like, whoa, hold on,
we can't have
an interracial kiss on TV.
So William Shatner
convinces them,
let's shoot it both ways.
We'll shoot it
with the kiss first,
and then,
we'll shoot it without,
and you can decide
what you wanna do in editing.
So they shoot the scene
with the kiss,
and then, he's like,
you know what, I have a note.
Let's try it again.
Let's do it one more time.
And they shoot it
over and over
and over again.
And they're like,
William, enough kissing, okay?
We only have time
to shoot this one more time.
And he's like, okay, let's
just do one without the kiss.
So it isn't until
the next day
that they watch the scene
and see that William Shatner
crosses his eyes
to the camera.
And they're like,
what the [bleep],
is this really happening?
And William Shatner was like,
I guess we either
have to air
this interracial kiss
or not have a scene.
And that is how
the first interracial kiss
gets on television.
- Wow.
- And then, in 1969,
America lands on the Moon.
And everyone in America's
like, oh, my God,
we landed on the Moon.
It's amazing.
And Nichelle was like,
uh, hold up,
that's all white dudes.
What the [bleep], right?
So she gives this big speech,
and she's like,
NASA, get your shit together.
Can you please recruit
someone to be an astronaut
who's not a white dude?
And NASA's like, okay, cool,
but, like, can you do it?
'Cause we don't know anybody
who's not a white dude.
So Nichelle Nichols was like,
ugh, black ladies
have to do everything.
So she travels
around the country,
and she recruits
people to be in NASA,
and she's like,
hey, black people,
Asians, lady people,
do you wanna go to space?
And they're like, okay, cool.
And she recruited Sally Ride.
And then, she recruits
Colonel Bluford.
He was the first black dude
to be in NASA.
- How cool is that?
- And then,
she recruited Mae Jemison.
And she was like, hey,
you should apply for NASA.
And Mae Jemison
is like, oh, my God,
you were on "Star Trek."
I love you.
But she's like, pay attention.
So Nichelle Nichols was, like,
the first black lady
to go to space for fake,
and she recruited
the first black lady
to go to space for real.
She literally
integrated space.
Everybody who's
really good at math,
or whatever
you have to be good at
to be--go to NASA,
can do whatever they wanna do.
- But we still need to prosper
if we're gonna live long.
- Yeah. [laughs]
- Is this America right now?
That's trying so hard, but--
- [laughs] Yes.
But it can't get over...
- But its ring finger
just can't deal with it.
[patriotic music]